what were the kind of ladies like that
you were dating before Megan I mean was
she part of a type that you were always
drawn to no no I mean she you know I was
confused I I was interested in romance
I was looking also you know for for
pleasures of the flesh and why are we
why are we in the New Testament that way
I feel like you just walked out of the
desert after a 1000 year hike I resisted
pleasures of the fact I walked a mini
Arad the the best one was I my first
long-term relationship I was really you
know I was in my late teens and I was
horny and and so I started dating I got
saved and started dating a born-again
Christian to try and learn about the
kernel parts of lovemaking what wait I
would think that would be the worst type
of person to choose you would if you're
horny why would you choose a born-again
Christian one would think but turns out
there's a lot of there's a lot of
pent-up desire in that sect so I mean if
you're if you're a teenager and you're
looking to get an education go to church
wait a minute so explain it to me you
would she would try and resist you'd
both well you were you going along with
this born-again Christian anything well
sure I mean you know I'm not a jerk the
walk yeah we you know we we were
teenagers and so we would try to be
devout Christians and then we would make
rabbit like passionate love and then we
would cry for shame yeah and then we
would pray that tomorrow night we could
resist the pleasures of the and that
became a cycle uh-huh uh-huh and as you
may know cycles are hard to break yeah
yeah yeah
so you well you ended up with I think
one of the the greatest ladies in the
history yeah the world Megan Mullally I
love her I I'm so grateful I mean no
kidding when you wake up and she's
laying next to you you you immediately
say okay what can I do today to keep
this gig that I've got insane sometimes
on his close-up he really does
did you see that where they were you're
talking
look at me
these are two people that took your gold
you